If your numbers for your AST, ALT and GGT are good, does that mean the liver is detoxed
at a good shape?
No, it doesn't.
Remember, your blood tests just give you clues, and they really give you clues of healthy
function or dysfunction.
And it can take a lot of dysfunction before those numbers get out of balance.
I would never say your blood all looks good.
Your liver numbers look good.
That means your liver is all detoxed.
Your liver is constantly detoxified.
If you're not detoxified, you are toxified and you're getting sicker.
So even if a person is a slow detoxifier, let's say their liver is not doing...
Let's say their liver is damaged and it's only functioning at, you know,
35% of its function.
You can still have normal AST and ALT and GGT.
Your liver is just only going to function at 35% of its function.
So your toxins that are circulating in your blood are going to be deposited in your
extracellular spaces and probably be stored in extracellular fat cells and other cells.
Your liver can store toxins.
And if your liver is damaged, you can't have elevated AST, ALT,
alkaline phosphatase, etc.
But, you know, your liver can be functioning far less than it should
and you could be very toxic in those numbers, it'd be normal.
So I wouldn't say that the liver is detoxed and in good shape.
Just because I have good numbers, we don't know all of that.
We don't know that for sure.